welcome to mastering the middlegame
my second edition today we're going to
be talking about restriction and how to
restrict our opponent species our
opponents plans first thing we need we
need to do when we're when we're talking
about restriction is anticipate our
opponents plan so this is a game between
Anand Anand is white against one of the
top American players get the camps key
I'm sure you guys know about him my
first question for you is what is blacks
plan in this position or better yet what
is the one piece that needs improvement
in this position for black thank you
very very good answer the bishop on ca
that's his biggest problem if he manages
to get his Bishop on from c8 out then I
believe black is absolutely out of
danger so how many how many plans does
he have to get that Bishop out you say -
okay which one's b5 Bishop e7 is the
main one definitely because it also
involves him getting his attack going on
on the on the Queen side was the second
one
a5 with Bishop e6 absolutely that's
another one Bishop d7 Bishop c6 that's
the third one so we have actually three
plans in which blacks get get out get
out of harm's way so I don't lose white
and I knew what he had to do so let's
try to let's try to find the best the
best move and the best plan in general
is g4g five pawn storm under on the
kingside right the problem is that as
I've said if black manages to to get his
Bishop out I actually think he's going
to be the faster one so uh not had to
shift kind of his mindset in this
position and and try to go for a
different Queen b6 okay what was the
point of that move
if I've ideas yeah and that's exactly
what a nun played Queen b6 very very
strong move black hat has to take he
simply doesn't have anywhere else to go
with the Queen Bishop takes b6 and okay
let's let's calculate a little bit
because it's not that easy
what if black plays Bishop d7 try to
calculate all the way to the end because
black has some defensive ideas
Bishop d7 a 598 absolutely that's
probably his main option if he takes
after Bishop d7 if you if I'd if you
take only five I'm simply going to take
and at least a pawn up right because
probably the best move is Knight d5
Knight takes d5 rook takes d5 and well
actually I don't have to take root takes
d5 because now I'm going to play Bishop
c6 and you might have some problems with
the g2 pawn but what is a much better
much stronger alternative for a while
Bishop f3 absolutely we're going to
prepare to take the d5 pawn with the
bishop and that's not going to give our
opponent any sort of counter play right
very good
the question is what happens after a 5
98
you have a few options try to try to try
to figure out all your candidate moves
because it's not that easy it takes D
six was the problem with it eighty-six
well actually if you if you take with
the night a 3-2 XD six night XD six I
can play Bishop c5 so if you take take
with the night I'm going to play Bishop
c5 and I think you're going to lose the
piece now yeah
so the best move in this position is
obviously Bishop takes d6 right now f4
is hanging so if you play that's kind of
the detail you cannot miss if you miss
then you're you're going to be in
trouble
Black has absolutely no problems here so
maybe after 98 yes after Bishop takes
the 6th root xt6 yes that's an option
but after taking with the night Bishop
c5 I can simply just move my knight and
that that was bass books that was
basically just an exchange I don't think
black should have any problems here so
maybe a more precise way after 98 you
have you have candidate moves maybe
they're not as obvious all of them so
try to figure that out very nice
absolutely Bishop c5 is the only move
that actually keeps some advantage what
actually big advantage going on you're
going to win upon if you take take and
blacks pieces are still restricted yeah
this Knight only eight is is now the
problem the problematic piece you're
also losing upon on b7 so the position
is simply just lost Bishop c7 was
another option but after 90-87 Bishop
takes d6 rook takes t6 Bishop c6 blacks
position is
very very safe yeah so very tricky move
Bishop c5 obviously gotta come ski being
gata Kamsky didn't play Bishop d7 he
played the move Knight to EA t' what is
he preparing to do
Bishop d7 and Bishop c6 right so now we
kind of have to abide by
I think steinitz said this this the side
on the attack has to continue making
strong move to strong moves to maintain
the initiative so once again let's what
does your intuition say how should we
continue
hmm if I've absolutely again we're
continuing with our plan of restricting
our opponent species it's a matter of
one move if you allow him to get his
species out all his problems are solved
so always always try to keep that tight
grip on to the position when when having
this type of initiative despite the fact
that this is the endgame this is not a
static initiative this is dynamic
initiative you make one bad move you
lose it so absolutely he played a five
now if black takes on only five I'm
simply going to take with the pawn and
how is this position hmm it's pretty
terrible for black I mean look at the
night look at the bishop look at the two
rooks his pieces are completely
paralyzed yeah all of them almost the
only one that's able to sort of move is
the bishop on his seven but not even
that one because if he leaves this
diagonal you're going to go Bishop c5
and the rook on f8 is going to be lost
right so he's not doing very well he
played the move d5 and this is another
critical moment of the position once
again it's time we we we make a plan so
there are two ways of restricting our
opponent's pieces one of them is simply
taking their squares away and the other
one is tying them up to the defense of
other pieces right and as you've
mentioned f5 and then Bishop g4 is doing
what
getting more pressures
mm-hmm and you're also tying tying this
bishop up to the defense of the e6 pawn
right right the bishop on d7 oh okay
again he would like to put his bishop on
c6 then maybe play rook c8 night c7
slowlyslowly
excuse me get his pieces out and then
once again he's not going to have any
clear problems but yeah after Bishop d7
well here there are two moves we can
either take on e6 first and then play
Bishop g4 or we could play Bishop g4
first the question is which one should
be the better alternative white Bishop
g4 I'm not taking on e6 thank you very
nice very nicely put yeah if you take on
his six the problem is he's not going to
take with the bishop he's still going to
take with uh with the pawn because
otherwise his d5 pawn will be in big
trouble but right now his rook is much
more active right so whenever you have
whenever you have the option of keeping
more pieces locked up try to try to do
that yeah it's it's much better not 90%
of the times it's going to be the right
decision to keep the keep the tension is
what we like to call it so he played
Bishop g4 gather played Bishop to c8 a
pretty difficult move to make but what
was White's threat in this position
yes take only six and whenever whenever
black takes back with the with the f7
pawn Knight takes d5 and the bishop on
d7 is hanging so he played Bishop CA a
difficult move to make but unnecessary
one if what if he takes on f on on f5
let's let's see Knight xt5 Bishop g5
Bishop e3 maybe I'm going to take Knight
takes
and you're still having a pretty nice
position you are correct but maybe after
after Bishop III I can do something else
maybe take here take
and what if I play something like f6
here does look a bit strange I agree and
you're probably still winning but I have
a feeling black is getting some sort of
counter play I have a feeling he's he's
able to complicate the position a little
bit once again I I think white should
still have the advantage but there is a
much more secure way of doing that in
this position I think Bishop f3 is a
much much safer option first of all
because you're keeping this night locked
you're keeping all his pieces lot and
after Bishop e6 or Bishop c6 we take
with the knight on d5 this looks pretty
bad for black there is also no risk yes
that's that's that's another important
concept whenever you're you have such a
clear advantage such a clear positional
advantage do you want to enter
complications ah yes I have a feeling
that no no you want to avoid
complications at all costs even if it
wins material again there are
complications and in complications you
can miss certain certain things and then
you're you're in big trouble
hmm so I think Bishop f3 is the much
safer option I'm pretty sure Anand would
have played Bishop f3 nevertheless I
cannot I cannot guarantee that obviously
so in this position he played bishop CA
what now
how to improve the position
roopd for might be a bad move because if
you play route before I'm going to play
Bishop g5 check King b1 and then Bishop
III rook hf1 absolutely absolutely
slowly slowly improve your position he
doesn't really have a clear threat right
so why not bring your pieces to do their
best positions black played a5 kind of a
desperate attempt at freeing himself up
what to do now well first of all what's
his uh what's his idea hmm rock a6
absolutely rock a6 is uh is an important
defensive idea maybe even a4 a3 to try
to break White's pawn structure little
bit on the Kings side though the main
the main the main idea behind the a5 is
obviously okay six all right kind of an
important moment white managed to find a
way to keep blacks blacks pieces tied up
quite nicely Bishop back to e2 is an
option
right but if you play Bishop it - I'm
going to play Bishop d7 because right
now as a consequence you don't have you
don't have the action on this diagonal
so right now you don't have F take F
takes c6 f takes c6 Knight takes d5
anymore
the bishop on g4 is securing kind of
your grip yeah
so I think the bishop is still doing
quite well over there let's try to go
thinking in a prophylactic manner
candidate moves interesting Knight to a4
what's uh what's the idea behind it you
have maybe you have some some ideas such
as a Bishop e2 or something like that
right yes 94 is the move and as you as
you've mentioned he has a clear threat
right now you're trying to increase the
pressure on on the e6 pawn with 95 if
you take if he plays Bishop takes e5
then Bishop takes d5 and the rock on f8
is is lost right
so yeah 94 is a very very strong move in
this position
rook d3 are okay six
but what's the point of brute eatery
right maybe you wanna like root lift on
the rank maybe route g3 once again you
need to you need to kind of choose a
stone you want to kind of focus your
forces on 94 you're kind of
concentrating your force is on on this
on this on this zone right especially
the e6 square
that's his a weak weak spot which one in
this position right 94
Bishop d7 95 and that's quite quite
quite a nice idea nevertheless I'm not
sure it it works I'm starting to have
ideas with Bishop which with Bishop b5
so maybe I can play something like this
we should be five I think you're still
doing better but I am not sure how this
position is okay you take on e6
obviously and then maybe I can play
something like f6 you did win a pawn but
I'm not sure if that improved your
position I'm going to play King g7 I'm
going to have some sort of blockade
against against your Bishop and then I
can get out yeah if you take on f6 I
simply take with the night and my knight
is is free so it's definitely once again
not something that you wanna you want to
do you don't you don't want to lose the
grip on the position you don't want to
simplify it as much so route III again
try to keep your your options and your
force is focused on one one target
rather than just kind of shifting focus
without any any reason behind it hmm
right so 94 he played 94 black doesn't
really have a lot of options in a
desperate attempt to complicate matters
get some counter play he played the move
f6 all right
the character of the position is
starting to change there are no new
targets that might we might be able to
focus our pieces on so what are our
options
okay he did play F takes c6 F takes e5
what now
Luke takes a fait King takes a fait
Knight f6
so whenever you take on d5 with the rook
I have this this idea of Knight f6
hitting the bishop and the rook you
always have to be careful what are the
consequences of the past couple of moves
black has freed up sure and now there
are there are different targets new
targets is the a6 is the e6 pawn target
anymore no because he's not there
anymore
but there's a new target yes
c5 could be an idea nevertheless we have
to we have to keep in mind that he is
going to free his his pcs quite quite
quickly after Knight f6 here Knight of 6
rook rook e8 and and the whole dynamics
might might be changing quite fast
mm-hmm Knight f6 is a serious serious
idea of blacks so we have to we have to
prepare a counter or we shift our focus
once again the consequences of the past
few moves there is there is a new target
guys in the d5 pawn
we cannot take it with a rope because of
of Knight f6 idea okay if we take rook
takes d5 directly the rock on f1 is
hanging but now we shift the knight back
to c3 right these are practically the
difficult decisions sometimes sometimes
we face we go one way and then and then
the whole situation changes on the board
and then you have to shift your pieces
back right right because now if you play
if you play Knight f6 directly I can
just simply take on d5 and that's just
going to be opponent right and actually
my my rook is penetrating on the d5 as
well yes
let's do this problems for him right he
takes with the king we take on d5 one to
two many targets yeah and you're you
still cannot develop your pieces so
there is a serious problems black is
facing in this position he's completely
lost so in this position he played
Bishop g5 first King b1 Knight to f6
critical moment once again what to do
we have a few a7 is an alternative 7 is
a candidate move absolutely but is it is
it the best we can do maybe not and if
not why so first of all why is c7 not an
appealing continuation
how is this position I don't know if
it's good for black but it's definitely
an improved version than what he had
with two bishops the pair of Bishops and
open center and and these two very very
attractive points very dangerous pawns
as well
d4 might be coming your pieces might be
drawn back and and and I think white is
going to face some difficulties
converting this we do not want that we
do not want to give to give our opponent
any chances any extra chances so let's
look for four different alternatives
Bishop c5 I think you're actually
helping me on helping me put my work on
yet attacking your e6 pawn why would you
want to help me you probably don't
I think I've heard a suggestion at the
beginning Knight takes d5 okay that's a
that's a critical load that's a critical
move you cannot really miss so let's
start let's start calculating that that
idea obviously what was blacks response
after that night xg4 takes takes your
piece if it takes on d5 you can simply
just take take on f8 King takes that
fate rook takes d5 and this is a an
obviously winning position yeah the
bigger question is what happens after
Knight takes d4 and we have to calculate
it from here because this is where you
make the decision this is where you play
Knight takes d5 you cannot play Knight
takes d5 without accurately calculating
all the complications after Knight takes
d4 hmm so Knight takes d5 Knight takes
d4 is 7 interesting move okay let's say
play rook e8 of 37 I think is the only
move actually
97 and how is that position mm-hmm how
does that position look like that looks
winning right yeah that's one of one of
the winning ways a seven Ruki 897 which
bishop the bishop on CA doesn't have
moves one still it doesn't have moves
that is the problem
you could try playing something like
Bishop e6 but I think we can simply just
take on a eight yes yes yes that is
there is also an option yeah I think you
have a lot of options to be honest at
this point you're already winning in a
lot of ways on I take c8 I think is
winning as well and after after this
maybe roopd eight I think there's plenty
of ways in which white wins this
position but Anand for some reason he
didn't play a seven
he played rook takes FA oops
it takes a fait King takes f8 how to
continue
once again I actually like we have to
calculate it all the way through Bishop
c5 King g8 he played 97 first okay and
now look to a six now this is another
critical moment of the game we have we
have several options and only one of
them well I think only one of them
clearly wins the other ones just give a
slight advantage
and it's all okay
okay so Bishop c5 I go king J there is
96 in this position which is the obvious
move and there is Bishop c5 which one is
the correct one and why why
okay very nice very nice new ones you
found over there yeah so after Bishop c5
King g8 how do you continue how do you
win the game B takes a 6 e 7 and that's
game over and
well if you just just as an example if
you take on a six first and then Bishop
c5 now I have the extra option of
playing King GA right
I go King yet and this is actually not
so not so not so clear I have two pieces
okay you still have an active an active
position as white but it's far from over
yeah Bishop d8 here Knight f6 or maybe
Bishop e7
now but this is a this is pointless yeah
I I mean you go in this position you see
Bishop c5 you see that he has to go King
g8 and after Knight x86 B takes a 6e
seven wins on the spot so you go for it
yeah but this was the last kind of trap
that a nun had to to avoid and he did he
played he played Bishop c5 Knight takes
a six comes he played Bishop Bishop
takes c6 ninety-seven Bishop v h3 the
position is completely completely waning
and raqqa fate
okay so it should be six like before
kowenski continued to play for a little
bit but
it's pretty easy it's pretty clear White
has absolutely no problems converting
this King III and he resigned that was
it
if you guys want to try to restrict
right now I have a position for you to
play whether you want it together like a
blitz maybe or something like that a
position between Richter and Parrish
this would be the position you guys want
to want to play it out or you want to
look at or try to solve the example try
to try to go through it it's black to
move what do you think actually let's
make it like this absolutely we're
talking about restriction so yes we do
have to restrict white species he let
let's go through it because we don't
have that much time
he played c5 Knight g3 how it continued
continued with the restriction I think
a5 is a blunder after h3
and this guy work is going to fall right
so he played h5 restrict this night
right f3 hmm
the night is going to go there but
that's not going to help him that much
because he's going to to get kicked out
via f5 so for example if you go right
now 94
I think I'm not even going to play a5
directly I'm going to play it for first
taking taking your your square on g3 now
I think I'm threatening to go with f5
and simply capture your night so the
night the night only for it looks good
but is going to be kicked out quite fast
with after I file so that's not what he
did
he played up three Bishop d7 rookie to
how to continue just play normal move
guys
b5
b5 restricting the other night we don't
have to actually hurry because I mean h4
probably would have been as good as b5
no no no he's not he's not very
concerned that's what he did but the
bishops controlled the entry scores
quite well on the e-file so he's going
to put his rooms there but he's not
going to do much more than that
Bishop FA now all the entry scores are
controlled right he has nice rooks on
the e-file but he cannot do much with
them so 94 what now
kg6 interesting idea
yes that's that's that's definitely
that's definitely part of his plan he he
played rugby a the same idea
to play a five to defend a g5 pole to
play to play a five but he wants to keep
his king on f7 he's closer to the two to
the center right it controls the
position a little bit better so he
played row J Knight b3 what to do now
restriction normal move rook c8 just
defendants if I thought we don't want to
play c4 or anything like that it's kind
of pointless to do that now we're not
we're not ready yet
yeah c4 ayah he can just simply take on
d4 and I think we're losing a lot of the
advantage so he played rook c8 night
edie to Bishop d6
94 bishop a fade a little bit of torture
a little bit of yes time control
management yeah a little bit of maybe
I'll give you the draw oops I'm not
going to give you the draw yes exactly
exactly and that's his that's blacks
point as well I did that many times you
know it's very frustrating for the
opponent and I was the subject of people
doing that against me and it is very
frustrating he played the f5 continued
pushing pushing the pieces backwards
teruki five
what now
you want to get active no no no no no go
back
rookie - what now if if if you play room
the rook d5 what's happening
Rock g6 yep rook g6 and the rock on d5
is going to be to be lost pretty soon
I'm going to go rook f6 defending the
five pole and then Bishop c6 you're
going to have problems right so he
decided to go back look eight we want to
push a five continue restricting the
pieces ninety-five what now
be careful be careful don't give your
bishop c7 hahaha no I don't think you
want to do that
after rookie seven you might have some
problems actually maybe even Knight b7
to be honest two threats I think you're
starting to lose the game it's the
beginning of your downfall so no not
Bishop c7 rook a to b8 of course
restriction Knight b3
h4 are we in a hurry now we're not in a
hurry give your opponent some some
hanging rope you know let him let him
make some mistakes you know don't don't
try to find you know the the winning
variation all the time just play normal
moves improving moves king h1 rook g6
kingi one Bishop to e6 as the arrows are
pointing out the king wants to transfer
on this side and then at some point
we're going to try to play for a 5 or c4
one one or the other we're going to see
which one works root cap to locate
Brooke II - mistake
what should he play in this pollution
mmm
let's calculate because black had some
ideas as well in mind
95 is is it's probably the best move I
think blacks plan in this position was
to play this and then Bishop a4 but this
might have given white some some extra
chances and after 95 Bishop e3 something
like c4 I mean you're still going to
have a clear advantage with with black
you're going to get that that exchange
but white is getting some counter
chances and I think this would have been
the much safe not not safe for a
comfortable way for white to play yeah
instead he chose to play rookie to and
now he started black started the final
squeeze a591 looks pretty bad right
a 492
let's look at let's look at his Knights
for just a second okay what now
come up with a plan probably a lot of
ways probably a lot of ways are working
in this position if we play g4 g4 is
what you mean
yeah we could try that but whenever we
play g4 he's going to take on g4 and
he's going to open up the f5 so and also
and also he's going to get if you move
your pawn from f5 if you take on g4 he's
going to get the e4 score for his knife
that's definitely something we don't
want so while while an offensive on the
Kings side looks quite appealing I don't
think he's the best the best version you
can you can get you have much better
plans
much more accurate plans hmm why Bishop
a4 if you go Bishop before I go Knight
to f1
see for absolutely why not why not an
offensive on on the queenside that's
where he has the least control of the
position yeah and why and your Bishop
are kind of pointed out towards that
side of the board why not take advantage
of it he played he played c4 of course
night with one rook to see a he wants to
kill his Knight he wants to completely
kill his knight King H 1 c3b takes 3
what now finish finish wipe off
a four year once again giving him
squares I'm going to go 94 95 I will say
thank you very much
don't give your your opponent's squares
I think it's time we I think this time
we go for some material in this position
and there is a clear way of just it's a
move but I don't think I don't I don't
think it's a good one because I just
take on a five right it's legal yes
white White's worse this the night on b1
can we get to him
before why not before and as that does
that game over you're going to take them
before I'm going to take on before with
the bishop a3 a2 the the best you the
best you will be able to do is actually
just sacrifice the night for the part
but that's going to be game over yeah
and it's a simplest move here it might
be practically challenging to make such
a move because you're exchanging
opponent maybe you don't want to
exchange points you want to kind of keep
tension and then keep as much material
on the board as possible but sometimes
you know when we improved our position
to the maximum we have to go for the
material we have to convert that that
you know that strategic advantage into a
more palpable one right which is the
night so yeah there before several moves
later he resigned but there is no need
to see more than it's just matter of
plan here you have to realize the only
way to to push his pieces back is with
with your pawns yeah and he doesn't
really have a way to respond to that so
right the bishops can control both sides
very very well and and also I think an
important part of this game is realizing
that him doubling up on the e-file
doesn't do much right it looks like he
does something but I'm just going to
push my put my pawn on my bishop on f8
my bishop on d7 and exactly exactly and
then I'm going to play h4 f5 and then my
rook on the sixth rank is going to to
swing and support the further expansion
on the Queen side yeah just expand your
parts right this is a this is a very
nasty position for a white very
difficult to play yeah so but you also
have to be careful like don't hurry you
hurry you give your opponent's squares
and that's going to cost you
you